richard branson the billionaire poster
boy for globalism and popping champagne
bottles a man who rubbed shoulders with
elites like nelson mandela
competitive wind surfer barack obama and
ex lifeguards david hasselhoff
he's a hot-air balloon enthusiast and
honestly is there anything more elitist
than that historically he's had his
hands all over media transportation and
giant credit cards his virgin group
holds 200 plus companies in 30 countries
he's such a globalist he pledged three
billion dollars to fight global warming
so he can continue looking at the earth
and be like yeah I'm all over that place
fortunately I forced him off his private
island to show him the real America the
back of a pickup truck park near the
West Side Highway in New York City
that's an American tea for you right
here American tea perfect I know that
you're a guy who likes to experience new
things have you ever done an interview
on the back of a flatbed with a grill
and some truck nuts think this is a
virgin first for me
glad I could pop that whatever cherry is
in England Sir Richard Branson your
globalist I'm an American it's
I read that you were at one point a
climate change skeptic and then your
mind changed so what closed your eyes I
decided to read up about it I met a lot
of scientists you're adding on the wrong
road right and about 99 percent of
scientists I think speak with one voice
and they talk a lot of sense what do you
think of the genius move to get out of
the Paris agreement now I believe to be
a mistake and very sad moved by America
the world came together in Paris to
agree that by 2050 we will make sure
that the world was powered by clean
energy not dirty energy and of course
it's not in the interest of Americans
because you know they're going to be
damaged from climate change their kids
are not going to do well out of a dirty
pollution of of cars and lorries lorries
trucks
[Applause]
apparently the globe wasn't good enough
for this globalist so he created Virgin
Galactic to also take over space I think
16 weeks from now we should be in space
about space why are you getting out of
here what do you know yeah well you know
we do know something about 50% of people
would love to get up there yeah
one day maybe have a virgin Hotel in
space what are the prices $300,000 to
experience space unbelievable how was
the common man gonna live out common
dreams like going to space and spending
tonight and a fancy virgin hotel yeah
well what happened with air travel back
in the 1920s and 30s people had a bit of
money started and then the price came
down and the common man now I think
benefits become aware is gonna have to
wait the common man's gonna have to wait
as a picture that came out of you wind
surfing with President Obama
what didn't we see in that picture was
George Soros off in the corner roasting
a pig with Hillary Clinton making pina
coladas you didn't see a swing stepping
and you might have seen this kitesurfing
it's elitist talk for are never gonna
rise to my level to understand the fun
things we do you and Barack are in the
same room are you talking about birth
certificates in single-payer health care
those ten days he wanted to chill he was
not wanting to touch the news talk about
anything serious he died eight years
about you guys aren't spending that time
planning who the next five presidents
are going to be oh no we know that we
sorted a lot yeah we're like a big I
couldn't disclose it tell me one of
them's not Ted Cruz
one of them's not Ted Cruz okay you have
a book right here finding my virginity
Richard Branson would you mind doing me
the honor of crossing out all the
globalist lies yeah okay what's it gonna
take for a guy like me to infiltrate
this globalist cabal and wind slash
kitesurf with men of power to understand
the machinations of the world around us
are you gonna have to lend a kite cephus
yeah if I was going to get answers I'd
have to take Branson to where he was
most comfortable in only this playground
unfortunately there was no time for that
so I put him in front of a green screen
all right
so consider us on vacation in beautiful
Switzerland a couple of guides of our
billionaires well we talk about the snow
we talk about skiing beautiful mountain
and then at the top of the mountain
lovely coats we then kill the goat so we
spill all of the blood and in their
entrails we decide who's going to be the
neck
commander-in-chief of America and that's
gonna be
[Music]